[Music]
hey
hey come
[Music]
thank
on
god
oh crap
hey brother we found you loose then
now get rid of her
oh
[Music]
oh crap
[Music]
[Music]
hey kid a little young for a bartender
aren't you a little old for prom aren't
you
[Music]
everything in here why the map it's the
biggest treasure that's never been found
5 billion easy but it's just a story i
beg to differ
[Music]
500 years ago
my family found the world's biggest
fortune
then was betrayed
people have been searching for it all in
vain
both you turn your keys clockwise at the
same time
thanks a lot you almost got me killed
[ __ ] why sully oh it was 50 50 so i made
a guess clearly
but the voyage was not just about gold
or something much more valuable this
gross has a very tragic history so much
blood
i'm pretty sure he's just threatening to
kill me
don't get caught
you were just gonna leave me back there
somebody had to get the cross
[Music]
wow
[Applause]
brother believed that there was a final
piece
well you know my brother said
you have no idea who you partnered with
what else aren't you telling me
the victor
spoils how are they going to get them
out of here
[Music]
hey put him down boys
what is that thing on your face
puberty's right around the corner kids
you can grow your own
exclusively in movie theaters
[Music]
you